raj
is with us in philadelphia hi raj
welcome to the dave ramsey show
dave and rachel huge fan of you guys
thanks for taking our call today
we're honored how can we help so uh my
wife and i
we uh came here to this country five
years ago from india
to do our masters and uh after our
masters we got
great jobs um you know thanks uh thanks
the country and also our
hard work i guess also the lord we got
into some good paying jobs and all of a
sudden
things that we couldn't have imagined
were reachable
um so we did splurge out in the
beginning we got some credit cards and
and then we realized that at the end of
the month we had more days to cover than
the money
um although we were making good money so
we got to know you and then we did a
complete 180 turn
uh paid off about 62 thousand dollars in
uh 10 months
um so again thanks to you guys and now
we are at uh baby step four
and uh we are doing that fifteen percent
uh uh
investments every month and i am a big
uh money nerd
um i'm a data uh scientist by background
so uh um
i'm so my question for you today is um
i we do allocate funds to our uh
401k and also the roth ira per year
instructions
but every day i look at it and it's
amazing to see
uh how the money grows every morning but
i'm
may i'm a little confused on which fund
would i choose
and is it okay to change the funds
within those groups
based on how they perform because within
those
four different sections you mentioned
some
perform well over another in a given
week or month right so so what is your
advice on that
i look at mine once a year and i have
mine split up 25 percent in growth 25
in growth in income 25 international
and 25 in aggressive growth and i don't
i do not obsess over it i don't look at
it every day
it is not unusual for me to go an entire
12 months without even looking at the
balance
uh because i did not buy it as a day
trader i bought it as a long-term
investor
now if i do look at one and the
fund category let's just say the year
the follow-up the previous 12 months
that that um
that growth in income fund did four
percent
and all the other growth and income
funds in the in the space
we're doing 10 or 12 percent then i've
obviously got a bad fund
i'll go ahead and make a move then uh
and move into a better growth and income
fund but i'm comparing it to
other funds in the space or what did
that particular category do what did the
aggressive category do
what did the growth and income category
do what the uh
the foreign funds the international
funds category do
and did this fund underperform over a
long period of time being a year
uh that category um
[Music]
and and then based on that i might move
one uh
consequently i almost never move a
mutual fund
because i buy stuff with good long track
records that are
known companies and they tend to perform
up to what the category is doing and so
i hardly ever
change funds you're going to have a
tendency because you're a data nerd to
jump in and out of funds and that's
going to cost you more than it's going
to make you
so i go with a buy and hold strategy and
i made a lot of money doing that
so that's the way we do it raj thanks
for calling in this is the dave ramsey
show